lead schoo Oh playing sunja Lane let's
play let's play gioco pianissimo all or
not I can play reverse walrus reverse
walrus yeah Alexa just doesn't want to
do what you're you're telling her to do
also why am I thinking here I should I
should know what to do let's play this
move
Oh majora oh that's French for hello ooh
okay interesting variation this could be
very fun take on me to do it do it you
know you want to
it's also not a bad move and it leads to
the most fun yeah this is I think I've
shown this maybe a once or twice on
stream where black makes a queen I make
a queen and it's relatively equal Wow
look at this for Queens for Queens on
move seven oh this is gonna be fun so I
defended a defend of the d4 pawn wait
does this just win on the spot Bishop h6
I could also take upon Oba shove h6
there's Queen a5 there's so many like
Queen checks to worry about
wait Queen d2 mmm that's complicated
oh wait Bishop h6 there's 97 I've forgot
that I can defend yeah let's take on on
each side no we're not gonna have music
this this stream if we have music then
it might mute for YouTube and this might
go on YouTube because for Queens maybe
soon to be six Queens if we if we both
make our each pawns into a queen
we both have outside passers on opposite
files
I think that like it's a relatively
balanced game a five okay do I play each
for each each we're makes a lot of sense
because passed pawns are meant to be
pushed yeah passed pawns are meant to be
pushed
oh my gosh okay well thanks Alexa thanks
Daniel
Merry Christmas happy happy everything
Wow
thanks so much also what does this move
okay let's develop a knight maybe I'll
make a pizza just for that I I
appreciate I appreciate the holiday love
but you you shouldn't leave like you
should not leave as we're both about to
make an additional Queen this is the
worst time to leave even after like all
those bits thanks again for the bits but
this is I mean
this is still getting more exciting more
spicy I assume I mean black might go for
this yeah I could plate Queen may be
Queen g8 first makes more sense someone
was asking why not Bishop h6 earlier
there is there was 97 defending
defending FAS queen e6 we need six
interesting this move should be too
actually about to happen this is so
ridiculous now I'm just I'm trying to
take this seriously and like objectively
play the best move now I'm calculating
this this we're black it's a free move
sorts checking me the King f1 my team
should be safe
I'm also calculating this move oh but
this move I've never mind
yeah let's play h6 this is so ridiculous
it's actually about to happen so now
there's this five Queens on the board
soon to be six Queens Knight before ya
night before it could be annoying but if
I'm checked somehow my king will just
move f1 and hopefully not get mated I'm
threatening actually to take on that
fates linking d7 I probably want a queen
first so many queens yeah so enjoy Lane
was saying earlier they prefer offbeat
openings yeah hello YouTube what does
Queen d5 it's like I could take and then
you know what I just realized
I couldn't I could triple bow to him I
could triple bow Ted scanned at this
game with three queens but no I want to
hold on to the Queen's for some duration
of time I'm just trying to make sure I'm
not getting me then like King f1 I'm
always safe yeah let's do this move what
a position and this is actually like
this the play hasn't been so
unreasonable I'm pretty sure blacks in
big trouble now
because if it can't be defended there's
there's only a few like random spy
checks the King f1 King so safe looking
black well i has three queens well
they're they're not doing anything to
target my king or help defend f aids
what a position oh this is so much fun
this is a crazy house so this is normal
chess we play the line so we actually
played like a line where you both get
new queens have another queen so i mean
for the most part that's been kind of
normal
i doubt more queens will appear king d7
yeah it's kinky seven probably best move
okay let's take a let's take a bishop so
i'm up a bishop here i have one extra
bishop but more importantly I'm I'm very
close to meeting the king like Queen
Queen Yeats Queenie a king g6 Bishop f4
oh there's gonna be so much fun so much
fun
you want four Queens
oh there's there's no passed pawns oh I
need to keep my pawns back to keep my
king safe promote the cheap on no
Queenie eights this is a point where
there there's no mercy like it really
hasn't been mercy for the past several
moons
wonder what is a record for the most
queens in a single game in like turn in
chess serious tournament chess no it's
at least four there's a game recently
and Grantchester
MVL versus ding with four Queens
okay let's get ready to have some fun
lon
I don't know why I'm counting just had
the instinct to count it feels like it's
gonna be forcemeat do this move yeah no
this is so close to me King d5 wall a
black one king of the hill where's the
mate I'm trying to conceive of like a
situation where I actually triple boat s
candids
because it's close like I could play
Queen d7 button
I'd like a play Queen e5 or maybe Queen
e5 first Oh work h5 rook h5 is a move
I'll see for is a move I'm just trying
to like conceive of some beautiful check
means I'm realizing actually there's a
way for me to go wrong I was thinking
here takes takes discover check but then
I lose this Queen and I'd be down a
queen she could be slightly hurtful I'm
actually like I'm not seeing force mate
yet it looks really good like I could
start with this move and f5 or catch
five f5 I'm not sure how much c4
actually helps it's hard to focus in
this position just so many Queens so
much to consider I really want to sack
I should start it with I cook sack Brook
sack or queen sack let's start with your
gauge 5 as it's not gonna hurt me I was
banking on this queenie 5 idea but i'm
not seeing how it works
this positions so messed up I could sack
uh my soccer rook
I'm sacking Eric doesn't appear to work
wait wait wait wait
Brooke takes off five Queen takes our
five Queen
oh there's nice mates Queen g8 Queens
Yates I think it works I think it works
let's do it
oh there's really nice idea Queen g8 so
I satoru I'm technically down I'm down
the exchange for a pawn but material not
relevant yeah you sick so now Oh
six why did I not see e6 I didn't see
six oh dear I have wait I have C for OC
4 could be nice
C 4 takes takes and then Queen takes he
6
the king has dragged up into my
territory let's play C for now I was
calculating Bishop e6 and Queen d7
Keeney 4 and then I'm meeting like
somehow but that's play C for this
better be mates somehow and this is only
move if this move person meets
Kiki for a while c4 explosive oh I think
black box should have taken I'm still
looking for the mates
actually I'm looking for the triple boat
as gambits
I don't think this queen is a soccer
ball
hmm okay let's just take a night yeah no
too much fun there's so many different
meats here I'll play it I'll say gee
three mains well I shouldn't premium of
G 3 because this was illegal what a game
a game you know I actually wasn't sure
thanks when jelly so I wasn't sure about
this line I was gonna take and then I
guess it should be winning yeah it
should be my name is 52 because King a 3
I can take Queen and King a 3 is
actually only legal move well the game
good game that was fun it's maybe too
much fun
Wow yeah computer will start analyzing
it no in this position I wanted to have
fun with Queen d7 and just attacking
from behind basically painting the
bishop from behind and then after this
my queens pins but I would have
basically the same mates with g3 yeah
thanks for the game I'll put this on
YouTube YouTube people hope you enjoyed
that computer graph I feel like the
computer just doesn't understand the
beauty of this so yeah well we'll save
that the reverse or whatever triple vote
as candidate for the future
oh yeah YouTube people hit the like
button I'll see you guys in the future